hello so like miles yesterday we has he
has a beginning slide to Center himself
I thought I would play a song to more
center you not me because this is
totally nerve-wracking to be playing in
front of people but but we'll see how
this goes what's the song about rainbows
by the way which is ties into this
oh man I messed up I'm just gonna stop
and I'll play a song later it might be
better cuz I yeah that's okay that was
scary okay so colors um I really like
colors um I hope all of you like colors
because you hear who uses hsl kind of
today a lot doing that okay love you
people cuz you're near and dear to my
heart who uses RGB a lot still okay
great love you people too because I can
impose my world view on you so hopefully
by the end of this talk you will decide
because of my my glam I plenty of
evidence that you should be using hsl so
RGB was RGB it's red green and blue so
these are this is an orange let's
simplify this a little bit so this is
red so the problem here often is like
you have like a red and you want a lets
you want a lighter version of that color
so when you're when you're just in red
green or blue it's pretty simple like
100 here you add some to that and you
get a lighter red and that makes kind of
intuitive sense so same same math works
out pretty easily if you're dealing with
pure green clear blue but you end up
getting into weird weird areas here when
like you're trying to do the same thing
with like this orange if you kind of
apply that same into it is kind of like
I'm just going to add some numbers to
this to this RGB triplet you end up like
you get a lighter color but it's not
orange anymore to yellow now and so say
i don't know like this blue it was zero
i'm not going to add to zero i'm going
to leave it 0 doesn't really help you
you're still yellow and really what
you're trying to do is you want this
this here to go from this orange so this
lighter orange but this doesn't make
sense anymore like you're adding her
like some red you're adding actually a
lot of blue and you're not adding much
green so that that really to me doesn't
make any sense and I don't think it
makes sense to humans
so what's going on here so RGB is if you
look at a monitor if you take like a big
magnifying glass to this monitor where
you go like stare up in that like that
projector up there and hopefully not go
blind then you're going to see like a
pixel is made up of four LEDs you get
like a red LED a green LED and a blue
LED and they're really close together
and they're really small and they turn
on and off at different like
brightnesses and so what they could be
off at zero or fully on at 255 and so a
different weight like a different
intensities and since they're so small
and far away from your eye your eye
kinds like doesn't perceive them anymore
and the light ends up adding together
and the light is really what's going on
and mixing together to kind of form a
different wavelengths when it hits your
eye so so yeah if you if you deal with
mixing lasers together all day long then
you should use our gb if not then i
would say that it's not cool anymore
it's not cooled and be memorizing RGB
hex triplets to impress your friends RGB
is not like brewing your own small batch
coffee with a cordless screwdriver
microcontroller it's more like this guy
on his commute in San Francisco on his
bus doing a line of cocaine off his
iphone our CP is it's not so uncool
that's cool again it's not cool um I'm
actually wondering what like this guy
sneaking out here he's like oh that's
good behind me oh he must be using RGB
too ok so RGB is a color space or color
mode or color model which I learned
yesterday where other names for it so
what is a color space sounds kind of
scary but not too scary it's like XYZ so
kind of like Cartesian coordinates if I
say that corner over the room 000 to get
to me you come like 100 feet along this
wall sorry about the imperial units I'm
a uninformed American like a meter to
this way and like two or three meters up
to my head and I can tell you where I am
in the room and so similarly to hear if
I kind of increased the red hear it
goes along this axis and because my red
if i increase the blue it kind of comes
off that that axis and it's kind of like
a purple and I can kind of come up and I
can see like there's this nice salmon
color here and you can kind of see this
entire space of color and it's cool so
you can like reference it's a good way
to reference colors um you get all these
Reds over here you get that graze up
through the middle and I saw a blue
corner but again to kind of go back to
the analogy of kind of or that example
of lightning a color I was like at this
orange and I really wanted to get like
over here kind of and what we were doing
is like we were kind of going up
straight this way so that direction and
that angle there like it it doesn't
really make sense and it's analogous to
like this position of where I am in the
room I want to tell everybody like an
emergency to exit through that door over
there I'm not going to be like oh you
know like a hundred feet that way and on
the wall and if I'm telling you in
relation to me I feel like these vector
math and I give you a relative vector
and that doesn't make any sense really
what I'm trying to say is like to my
right I'll hundred feet that way right
and so that's polar coordinates if you
remember from like I don't know sixth
seventh grade geometry which I remember
learning and thinking like this is weird
but the one takeaway I remember from
polar coordinates is that if you kind of
reframe your problem or kind of change
is a problem statement actually ends up
with sometimes simpler answers like this
where like I can say to my right and 100
feet so that's kind of why I want you
here so I would say let's make our own
color space what do I want out of this
color space is I want to be able to
communicate to another person somewhat
intuitively like what color I'm talking
about and I want to make like performing
tasks on those colors more intuitive for
so you can like reason about it from
first principles and so how would we do
that so let's for example if I won't
want to describe the color of Jake the
dog here he's like a must so if I'm
gonna try to tell you the color of Jake
the dog out I wouldn't give you our GP
triplet i would i would probably say you
know he's like mustard yellow or to kind
of
break that down a little he's yellow
kind of like a muted yellow and kind of
darker especially compared to like this
yellow in this rainbow back here so
let's break down kind of what I more
naturally did to describe that color
let's take that rainbow which I alluded
to at the very beginning with that badly
played song and just put into an array
of because we like to put things into
arrays of let's start with 12 colors so
I get the entire rainbow here this is
roy g biv so red orange yellow greens
some random cyan a blue maybe this is
indigo maybe this is violet who knows
and if I kind of just increase the
number of buckets here we get to a nice
little rainbow and as you notice like
these are kind of thirds so red is at
zero greens at a third blues at a third
and kinda you get back to read so I'm
just ignore ignore why I'm doing 360 but
i'm going to go 360 because it does make
dividing this in the Third's a little
easier this is 120 so greens at 120
blues at 240 and it kind of wraps around
at 360 back the red so that specifies a
color like on a rainbow great that's one
large step so how do I talk about kind
of like the color of the sky or like the
muted sea green so if I want to like
describe the nice mute like cast over or
overcast the blue outside for the sky I
need to talk about saturation so if I
pick a color on this rainbow like this
this nice little blue here pretty close
and then I want to like yeah on the
scale of one to ten I'd say the sky is
somewhere around like a five today at
least earlier now it's actually a lot
brighter and again like to work with
more colors here let's just go up to a
hundred ok so now that gives us a lot of
vocabulary ready so it gives us again a
hue a color from the rainbow and then
kind of how colorful that is and at that
at the end of the spectrum spectrum at
zero it's like the lack total lack of
the color so gray so you'll be you'll
notice that you were missing black and
white here to kind of talk about black
and white
I would kind of say it's kind of how
much light is falling on color how
bright the room is in a sense so if we
turned off all the lights in here it
would be all black and we be in darkness
if we turn the lights way up to like
crazy levels we'd all be blinded and we
just see white that's my story anyway so
again same get the gate 1 i'm going with
this so let's go to scale 100 0 to 100
at the total lack of light where
darkness and at full-on lightness we're
all blind and we see white I'm at 50 is
like that nice sweet spot where like you
see all the colors in the room nicely ok
let's put all together so that I just
backed out hsl so hue saturation and
lightness that's why it just all stands
for so again you can kind of see how
everything ties like this is RGB down
here and this is hsl appear you can kind
of see how if I change like rotate
through is Hughes how like the RGB
values kind of move around a little bit
in a weird way goes through like some
weird permutations if I pick a color
here and like a brightness here and I
kind of so if I go to like full
saturation so this this pink actually
want to use let's use it's like blue
again so if i'm at like fulbright so if
i start down here and i slowly ramp this
up i see blue and green going up but no
red and as i keep getting further like
red finally starts to kick in and it
kind of goes higher so that it kind of
makes sense again I'm not going to be
able to tell you what color would cause
what to happen the other cool thing may
like relationship that kind of makes
sense is as you go from like full
saturation down the left saturation
these like red green and blue is kind of
all merge together which again maybe
make sense if you if you play with this
it so great so I can specify color
hopefully more intuitively than RGB to
another person so what about making
doing some stuff with those colors so
back to the original example just
lightening this orange so I have human
saturation specified
and all I do is increase the lightness
so that's a lighter version of orange
this is me at the dentist with my
hygienist Linda and my little dog Coco
who likes to go with me and make sure
that Linda's not going to mess me up and
so if I went a nice gray scale version
of this photo I would just desaturate
these colors and I get this this more
timeless photo or like in my just one
like maybe a cool washed out version i
can go to like around here so that's
great scaling a photo that's cool um and
if you saw Amy's talked yesterday about
making art or you played with the lights
in the other room this also comes up
often is they were using it yourself for
a very specific reason and that's
actually if you've ever tried to like
make a color palette with RGB it doesn't
make any sense like everything else but
if you just okay so say let's pick yeah
like a nice red all right I kind of like
this like this cool looking red right
here I like this red based on saturation
lightness values I just pick and I just
rotate through all the hues I end up
with like colors that kind of fit
together and they they they go together
if you tried to do this without you be
you end up with all these weird colors
that just don't look right okay
hopefully I've convinced you that hsl is
really awesome and you want to use it so
how do you use it so it's already kind
of everywhere you guys cough website
check out the body so this is in RGB hex
triplet if you mouse over this it even
tells you now you can shift click and
you can see all these different color
space things and you can edit this and
if I just kind of change the hue it goes
through all the hues so that's pretty
cool and so all the tools that you use
that support RGB I'm i will bet you some
money maybe not a lot of money but some
money that they will also support hsl
and CSS like sports hsl all the browsers
support hsl you can just write that out
and so there's some maybe not support
forward
a preprocessor or other thing will
actually just translate it for you okay
so ah so I was just telling you all
these cool things about hsl so if you
were to say take all the people in the
world that we're really excited about
like color and lighting and like they
have conferences together they're
actually called the commission
internationale de lis damage or cie for
short it's kind of like all of us except
who really geeked out about color and
lighting and like how the eye works and
they like get together and have
conferences except they call them
symposiums and and they talk about all
the stuff so they actually have they
publish their own color space it's
called cie lab that is actually probably
cooler than hsl um it's like the new the
new Frank Ocean album of hsl not con
Yenny well he's so passe oh so so if you
want to talk about cool color spaces i
would love to talk to you about lab and
let's see i do want to end on a song
okay are there any Elvis Presley fans in
the audience okay good oh sorry then I
apologize ahead of time because i'm
going to do injustice to his song okay
let's see
would it be I guess like a.j scoff has
surely too much react dan so it goes
that something take my advice all right
everyone like a.j is conf has surely too
much react and so it goes that something
to my word take my own advice cuz i can
using H and sell high kiss no using H
falling in love with you right ah so
thank you my name is Disney um these
slides are at this nugget hub that I oh
that's my name with a p on the end
github you probably use it I owe some
islands hsl so this is actually this is
this kind of reasons a blog post if you
actually go go through these slides so
if you are too lazy to convince your
coworker and you're convinced also of
yourself that you should use hsl you can
point them as these slides and they
should make some some sense by
themselves thank you again